I mean there's just one question that
you have to ask before talking about
this one are you my mummy
[Applause]
[Music]
alright the obvious and cheesy intros
out of the way let's talk about what I
have gone on record as saying was my
favorite 9th doctor episodes while
episodes story the two-parter which
means we are talking about the empty
child and the doctor dances oh alright
I've really been looking forward to this
one I'm really enjoying going back and
re watching these and seeing them was
slightly pressurise this one was the one
that I was pretty sure was gonna have I
was gonna have the least new to say
about I mean like these are overdue
reviews so I haven't done a review
specifically about this story before but
I talked about it before and there
really isn't much more to say because
this is one that I have rewatched
repeatedly a number of the things that
I've covered as I've started going
through these things again are things
that I haven't rewatch in a long time or
in a couple in cases I don't think I
ever watch them a second time at all so
it's been it's been interesting but
here's like this is just gonna be nice
to watch and I I do love the
synchronicity that the date that this
happens to land on because these are
coming out on Wednesdays happens to be
Halloween I think if I'm gonna have a
doctor who review come out on Halloween
it is very fitting that it is this one
so where do we even begin now I've I've
said actually fairly recently that I
generally don't care for Doctor Who's
historically set episodes and watching
this one again it occurs to me I should
clarify that what I don't care for is
the Doctor Who historical episodes that
center around a known historical figure
when it's just set in the past
and doing its own Doctor Who thing that
doesn't bother me so like I don't have
an inherent problem of that nature would
say fire some Pompeii and I definitely
don't have it with this so I'll go
stories with Charles Dickens or
werewolves of Queen Victoria aren't
exactly my jam
when dr. who feels like dropping me down
in the middle of London Blitz for creepy
gas mask monster children and a suave
time-traveling comment yeah I'm kind of
all over that and this is so good I mean
it's so good in so many levels it's it
is a cool story it's a cool idea
it's a neat setting it's gotten the
introduction of a great new character it
has a creepy antagonist and so it's plan
it's got some of the best just dialogue
and little bits and moments and snippets
bananas are good you know all they
forgive me when I do that when I try and
do the accent I know I suck at it but I
just I love all this stuff that is going
on here it's all just phenomenal Andros
is great in this I love rose sort of
experiencing a little bit of not
necessarily fatigue with the doctor
being like huh I mean I'm liking this
but I wish he was kind of different than
meeting jagang me like oh well hello and
of course Jack Oh Captain Jack Harkness
you dog it's really it's funny going
back and seeing if we'll see him this
young first of all I said boy I say that
pretty sure he was he was within a year
of my age right now when he was in this
oh boy
so in any case like he's he's great he's
awesome and in just the the suave and
the easygoing nature and even when he's
pushed against the wall and has to own
up to being a con man just his annoyance
at everything I was like look this was
supposed to be just an in-and-out just I
get what I wanted I go away job why is
this dragging on and the frustration
could have come off as bratty but it
doesn't here he legitimately doesn't
feel like he caused this problem so he
doesn't feel he should have to deal with
it however he does
up and take responsibility once it is
revealed to him oh no this is in fact
more fault so I like that it feels I
mean especially with what we see later
from him feels very proper to the
character that when he is able to tell
himself not my fault not my problem yeah
he kind of wanted ducks out but once he
knows that isn't no he'll he will step
up and power to him forth and Eccleston
is just great Ellison gets to do so many
things in here he gets to be light and
you know just sort of approachable
especially when he's talking with the
kids like around that that dinner table
I love that I love that entire dynamic
that he has you know I love how
easygoing he is with these kids I love
the sense of empathy that he has when
trying to figure out how to deal with
the empty child like he's getting the
warning from Nancy you know don't let
him touch you that's not a child but
he's he's going this is this is a kid
outside not being let him for food
what's going on his his empathy really
comes to the surface in this which i
think is good because it also you know
you you never lose that sense of damage
with Eccleston's doctor specifically so
I am loving all of that and I you know
it also has one of my single favorite
moments in Doctor Who of all time but I
will get to that we will get there so oh
man like I I could just I could just
list everything that's going on here the
nighttime during the Blitz is really a
terrific or horror spooky kind of
setting because the the nature of the
situation already has so much
uncertainty about it and did you inject
this child into it and that gas mask oh
man that that just works and the thing
for me what is especially terrifying
about this this thing is that it never
loses it is simultaneously retains that
sense of innocence but you never for a
second think that it is anything other
than
deeply dangerous and there's something
about that mix especially for me
especially because and anything this
probably I think I felt this at the time
but it hits me harder now now that I
have a kid when kids are around that age
because I I think Jamie's probably about
four ish and especially at that age like
kids don't have a fully developed sense
of morality of right and wrong they know
what they've been told is right they've
known Ben told is wrong but they're
still kind and they're they're you know
far enough along to sort of know they
know what they want but they don't
always recognize the problem with
getting what they want so when you imbue
a child at that mental level looking for
its mother with the kind of power this
thing has what you have is as the doctor
says there is no little boy on the
planet who wouldn't tear the world apart
to save his mother and this one can
that's what's scary about this this
thing for me on a conceptual level it's
that it has the power to destroy the
world in its search for its mother and
because it has the mind of a small child
it does not understand or recognize the
damage that it's causing versus the good
that it might feasibly do if it succeeds
it doesn't care it just wants its mother
and just knowing how kids can be that's
I guess it's legitimately scary and
besides just the inherent creep factor
of a very small child with a gas mask
going are you my mommy
I mean and you know that sort of that
always works and then the whole thing
with them and being able to talk through
various things through the radio through
the typewriter which is ridiculous I
know that it is but I don't care because
it's an awesome reveal on that moment
like it's just it works it just
and Rosa like I'm coming back to her
again so like I like her I love her
dynamic with with Jack but also I like
wit kind of brings out see I don't read
what's going on between her and the
doctor here as flirtatious I see almost
more as teasing the way you know some of
my T's like uh like a slightly older
route like an older cousin or or you
know someone like I'm like an aunt or an
uncle who's you know within 10 15 years
of your age so you that that sort of
jabbing and ribbing on the notion of
well has the doctor ever danced and but
at the same time there's enough of it
that I can see where once the doctor
becomes tenant you can build that into a
more flirtatious relationship but I
don't feel that it got there in this
episode which I'm good with because I
don't like the doctor flirting with the
companions but I feel like here it
really it thread the needle of touching
on those nerves without at least not to
me feeling like she was ever coming on
to him which I just appreciate it and
the the I get think the other thing with
Jack is that number of people when I've
talked about sexuality displays in and
doctor before have brought up the doctor
and Jack and I again I don't get a
direct flirtatious thing I think the
line everyone gets on is that Jack gets
on the TARDIS and Rose has this moment
of you know I think Jack wants to cut in
because she was dancing legitimately
dancing but we know what the metaphor is
in this with the doctor and the doctor
goes I'm sure he does rose but who would
I don't think that's him flirting with
Jack I think that's him teasing Rose
that she can't be that sure that he was
that Jack was flirting with her again I
don't read that as the doctor actively
flirting but you know what is probably
interpretable so if people have read it
that way okay I still don't that but
yeah no I love it so before I get to my
absolute favorite thing about this
episode I think it's worth it
Knology is this a perfect episode no
there are a couple of little tight end
they are tiny these are knit picks but
this is me also you know very much
trying to be as objective as possible
and in these rewatch is i want to really
closely examine the things that i like
to be sure that i understand why i like
them and to pick up any issues that I
may have missed before and the things
that I haven't like try and find the
good in them that maybe I couldn't see
before how am i succeeding I don't know
you tell me but there are only two
things and one of them actually did bug
me a little even on first viewing but it
bugs me more now and the other one
really bothers me on the rewatch but I
still think it's a little much so the
first thing is that there's really no
point to the mislead about dr.
Constantine because Nancy tells the
doctor tells Eccleston you know you need
to go see the doctor and like there's
this whole huh and it's played up
mystery like he's gonna go and meet
himself but the fact that he's just
going to see a doctor a normal doctor
like this is truly no point to that even
a hint of a mislead so I don't really
know why the episode does that
thankfully it doesn't spend a lot of
time building that up he gets to that
location fairly quickly meets dr.
Constantine we move on so it it doesn't
drag things down or build too many
expectations that it can't deliver I
just don't know why that happens like at
all and the other thing is I do think
that the empty child especially towards
the the end is basically speaks too much
and I say that you're like what are you
talking about all he ever would like
practically all he ever says is argue my
money that's kind of that's kind of my
point he says that like a few too many
times especially in close succession and
again thing that one didn't bother me so
much on initial viewing but on a rewatch
once the the creep factor has kind of
eased off a little bit because I know
what I'm dealing with I am going like
they think they've got him saying that
like two or three times too many like in
the stretch of like a minute
so I don't know that's nitpicky but
let's again oh I need to talk about my
favorite moment of this and one of my
favorite moments in Doctor Who everybody
lives but the thing is it's about the
build-up to that moment it is not just
the doctor going everybody lives
what makes this moment amazing is the
lead-up is the doctor having basically
told everyone around him we can't win
we're doomed and he'll maybe in the back
of his head yet vague hope that Nancy
connecting with this child would do what
it ends up doing but you get that sense
of haha from him when it starts
happening he wasn't expecting this to go
well he may have been hopeful but
there's a sense of desperation where
he's sort of pleading you know come on
figure it out and then he goes up to the
child to Jamie
he just pauses before taking the mask
off and he goes oh please give me a day
like this give me this one and the the
death of pleading in his voice of
needing this to work so badly that is
what makes his elation at everybody
lives truly soar I think it's a good
moment regardless but with that buildup
it is solid gold it is amazing and I
love it and honestly it chokes me up
when he is fleeting you know in those
moments before he takes the mask off and
he is so desperate I did it chokes me up
and I'm more so than the everybody lives
moment which is still a great moment
it's a great capper on that but he plays
that the weight of all the times that
not everybody lived or maybe he was the
only one who lived all culminating and
and he trying so hard to claw out of
that he plays all of that in that moment
so brilliantly
god I love it and then he gets to ride
it for a little bit longer you know get
getting on to getting back onto the
tardes you ask me anything I'm on fire
oh god it's good I really love this
two-parter one of my favorite stories of
Doctor Who period I mean I'll be certain
once I finish series one but I think I
can still safely say my favorite
Eccleston story and what are your
thoughts on the empty child and the
doctor dances whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff you can do because there's buttons
and there's links down there check them
out if you feel like it if you don't
don't sweat it because you know what at
the end of the day folks you are the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]